Schönen.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ali Ali. Ich bin ein zuständiger Arzt für Sie.
Ich würde gerne etwas aufnahmigesprechen. Sind Sie für einen Verstand?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Tim Schröder.
Tim Schröder.
Und Vornamen bitte.
Tim.
Tim Schröder.
Ich bin ein Mann.
S-C-H-W-Schule.
R-O-Umblaut-D-G-R.
Können Sie wiederholen bitte?
S-C-H-R-Umblaut-D-R.
Schröder.
S-C-H-R-Umblaut-D-W-Düsseldorf-D-R.
Okay, danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Schröder.
Also sage ich das richtig. Ausdrücke ich das richtig.
Schröder sagen Sie genau richtig.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
58 Jahre alt.
58.
Okay, warum wurde unser ganz genau geworden?
Am 12. März 64.
Wie viel Wegen Sie so zeigen?
Ich wiege noch 70 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
180.
Danke schön für die Information.
Herr Schröder, was füllst du zu uns? Was kann ich von dir tun?
Ja, wir sind, ich hab mit einmal so heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Und ich hab so Darmprobleme.
Also mal habe ich Durchfall, mal bin ich komplett verstopft.
Und jetzt sind die Schmerzen um den Bauch um oder im Bauch so heftig geworden.
Dass ich gedacht habe, ich muss jetzt mal dringend zum Arzt kommen.
Also das ist ganz unangenehm.
Insbesondere ist es ganz schlecht, wenn ich auf die Toilette muss.
Egal, ob ich Verstopfung habe oder ob ich Durchfall habe.
Dann habe ich solche Schmerzen.
Ja.
Das kramft sich alles so zusammen.
Das sind so Wellen. Mal gehen die Schmerzen ein bisschen zurück.
Und dann sind sie wieder ganz stark.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwarte?
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist in letzter Zeit, dass ich ein bisschen schlecht Luft kriege.
Also auch wenn ich nicht anstrengen, dann, dann,
wenn ich so ein bisschen Luft nötig und wenn ich eine Treppe hochgehen muss
oder eine schwere Tasche tragen, dann komme ich richtig aus der Puste.
Okay, verstanden.
Also seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden am Anfang wie Bauchschmerzen?
Nicht meine, ja?
Das sind so guter Monat, fünf Wochen, sechs Wochen.
Also Atemnot.
Auch auf der Seite, umgefetzt.
Okay.
Also ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen, ja.
Wir haben seit fünf, sechs Wochen heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Also mit Durchfall und Verstopfung.
Also sie ist krampfartig, wellenformig, ja, so.
Und so gleichzeitig leiden sie an auch Atemnot, ja?
Ja, so kann man sagen, ja.
Und schlapp fühle ich mich.
Ich fühle mich allgemein total schlapp und habe so das Gefühl,
puh, es schmeckt mir nicht.
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Also ich bin so ganz unzufrieden mit mir.
Die Müdigkeit haben Sie auch gelöstet.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkarre?
Von 1 bis 10, wobei 1,
sehr leichten Schmerzen entspricht, ja,
10 unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einschätzen?
Also vielleicht so ein bisschen über der Hälfte, so bei 6 vielleicht.
Also unerträglich ist natürlich ganz was anderes, aber das sind schon starke Schmerzen, ja.
Das ist eine krampfartige Schmerzen.
Ja, die kommen wirklich wie so Wellen, ja.
Okay.
Also strahlende Schmerzen,
also irgendwo hinaus, zum Beispiel oben oder unten.
Eigentlich sind die überwiegend so um den Bauchnagen herum,
da habe ich da so wiegen, also ob das die Zielscheibe ist, ja,
und mitten im Bauch.
Da sind Schmerzen aber direkt ausstrahlen, irgendwo hin, zumindest.
Also ganz Bauch, meinen Sie nicht?
Nein, das tut, also überwiegend ist es so um in der Mitte.
In der Mitte.
Am Anfang war auch da oder?
Eigentlich sind die von Anfang an da die Schmerzen, ja.
Da war immer da, ja, okay.
Also ist Ihnen auch gefallen, gibt es bestimmt jetzt
eine Schlöser für die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel,
Essen, Trinken oder?
Da ist mir jetzt eigentlich nichts aufgefallen,
wie das so, was ich nur, was ich schon gesagt habe.
Also wenn ich auf die Toilette muss, wenn ich also Stuhlgang habe,
dann sind die Schmerzen in dem Augen gerade ziemlich kräftig.
Nach dem Toilette, meinen Sie, oder vor dem Toilette?
Eigentlich, weil, während ich auf der Toilette gehe,
ich habe eine Schmerz, die auf die Toilette gehe.
Ach ja, okay.
Also gibt es etwas, dass diese Schmerzen lindert
oder verstärkt, außen bewegen, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben so seit auch, leiden Sie auch,
Müdigkeit, ja.
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was das besser macht.
Also vielleicht Ablenkung, ne, wenn ich das,
wenn ich mal nicht dran denke, dann geht es ein bisschen besser, ja.
Okay.
Also sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter oder?
Die sind schon dauerhafter, aber manchmal kommen die halt...
Verstärkt jetzt nicht, ja.
Einige, die Schmerzen etwas eingenommen, oder?
Nein.
Eine Schmerzmedikamente oder?
Also ich habe wohl Ibuprofé im Haus,
weil ich halt immer mal wieder Probleme mit den Knien habe
und da kann ich Ibuprofé nehmen, aber ich habe jetzt dagegen
eigentlich nichts eingenommen, weil mir das irgendwie so neue Schmerzen waren.
Okay.
Du brauchst Schulter.
Ich bin ein Mann, ich meine, Mann, Tim.
Entschuldigung, ja, das ist etwas schwer, ja.
Herr Schroeder, war Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz vor dem Augen?
Haben Sie so etwas gemerkt?
Das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Sie haben eine Müdigkeit abgeschlagen, deswegen fragte ich Sie.
Ja, ich finde, total schnapp, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schulterfroß oder nach Schweis?
Oh ja, nachts schwitzig, tüchtig, das stimmt, ja.
Und jetzt war es natürlich auch sehr heiß im Sommer,
da schwitz man schon auch von alleine, aber ich habe schon das Gefühl,
dass das mehr war.
Okay, aber Sie haben Fieber nicht gemacht, ja.
Ich habe Fieber nicht gegen Wasser, aber ich habe mich auch nicht wirklich fieberig gefühlt.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie einen Druschfall haben, ja.
Ja.
Wie viel waren müssen Sie täglich auf der Toilette?
Ja, manchmal viermal am Tag, dann kommt so ein ganz klein bisschen
und manchmal kann ich vier Tage nicht, ja.
Manchmal leiden Sie unter einem Fest-Sport-Mach.
Ja.
Und dann traue ich mich natürlich auch nicht irgendwas dagegen zu tun,
weil ich dann genau weiß, woher dann sitzt ich wieder einen ganzen Tag
und habe nur Durchfall, ja.
Okay.
Waren Sie schon mal beim anderen Eis wegen diese Krankheiten?
Ja, also vor langer Zeit war ich mal, war ich jetzt in Behandlung
und immer wieder bei meinem Arzt wegen, wegen Hämorrhiden, die ich habe.
Und die sind immer wieder behandelt worden, aber das sind ja andere Beschwerden.
Also damals gibt es nicht ähnliche Beschwerden, ne?
Nein, da ist mir halt nur aufgefallen, was das übliche,
dass das unangenehme ist und das Blut im Stuhlgangen ist und so was.
Und das habe ich gesehen und ja, das kenne ich also auch so vom Aspekt her.
Aber solche Schmerzen hatte ich da ja nicht.
Herr Schruhner, wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ja, zurzeit ist ja nicht so gut.
Wie meinen Sie?
zurzeit schmeckt es mir nicht besonders.
Appetitlosigkeit.
Ja, es ist nicht so toll.
Ich habe auch tatsächlich ein bisschen abgenommen.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit 3 kg abgenommen,
ist mir aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie in der letzten Zeit, können Sie eine bestimmte Zeit geben?
Also 3 Monate.
Ich wieg mich ja nicht so oft.
Also ich denke, 6-8 Wochen so, ne?
Herr Schruhner, haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchschlafen?
Einschlafen klappt nicht so gut, ja.
Haben Sie noch sonst etwas Ungewöhnliche bemerkt?
Herr Schruhner, ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen alles erzählt, alles andere.
Was Sie haben für mich?
Okay, brauchen Sie?
Ja, das muss ich ja zugeben.
Ja, zu rauch, Rol, ich haufe seit 15 Jahren.
Und ich rauch 2 Packungen am Tag.
Ich habe viel Strecken, ich bin leerer.
Und in der Schule darf man zwar nicht rauchen,
aber dafür zu Hause ist dann unsere Meer.
Und wenn ich korrigiere und Unterrichtsruhe bereite,
dann rauch ich halt viel.
Tränken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trink schon,
als war es ich abends mal ein, zwei Gläser Wein.
Ein, zwei Flaschen Wein?
Ein, zwei Gläser.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Ich habe ja mit den Schülern Ärger, ich bin leerer.
Da hat man an der Schule schon mal Ärger mit Drogen,
aber ich selber habe dann nie das probiert.
Das ist ja gut.
Schreuder, ich möchte über etwas Ihre Vorerkrankungen,
Krankgeschichte, etwas bisher,
gibt es bestimmte Vorerkrankungen bei Ihnen im Beckern,
zum Beispiel Suckerkrankheit, Blutobrug, Schöckbräuse
oder chronischen Darerkrankungen?
Also, was ich habe, das bist du seit zehn Jahren bekannt,
das ist ein bisschen erhöhter Blutdruck,
da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette Weisartan.
Und dann hat man irgendwann festgestellt,
ich hatte immer so saures Aufstoßen
und das ist mir nicht gut bekommen.
Und dann hat mein Hausarzt mir Omel Prazol verstanden,
das nehme ich jetzt.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, dass sie Kneeprobleme aufhaben, oder?
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich seit zwei Jahren,
das ist mir bei den Knie bei Gelastung weh tun.
Okay.
Und Hemorrhäten haben Sie auch geschwaut?
Genau, die Hemorrhäten, die machen wir jetzt auch seit ein paar Jahren zu schaffen.
Da sind schon mehr Kampf zu Bandligaturen gemacht worden.
Und das letzte Mal war vor zwei Monaten.
Und noch was, das war alles, oder?
Nein, das reicht ja wohl, ne?
Ja, das haben.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein,
außer, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie wegen Blutdruck
warst Artan, oder?
Warst Artan, ernernt sich durch Sie,
und wie häufig nehmen Sie das an?
Also ich weiß gar nicht, was da drauf steht.
Ich nehme da morgens eine.
Und Omel Prazol nehme ich meistens eine.
Und wenn ich mal mehr Beschwerden habe,
nehme ich da auch mal zwei Tabellen.
Ich verstehe.
Okay.
Herr Schröder, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben beide noch.
Also, leider ihre familien Angehörigkeiten
an chronisch in der Krankung, oder nicht?
Meine Mutter ist top gesund.
Und bei meinem Vater hat man jetzt festgestellt,
dass der Darmkulm hat.
Aber das ist nicht ganz gesund.
Also die Mutter ist gesund, aber die Eltern sind noch.
Also die Mutter ist gesund, aber der Vater hat Polypen im Darmen.
Das hat man bei so einer Darmenuntersuchung festgestellt
und hat da ein bisschen was entfernt.
Also das ist nicht gefährlich,
ich habe etwas gefunden.
Ja, genau.
Das ist einfacher Polypen, meinen Sie?
Genau.
Also das war ein wenig aufregend.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Ich möchte etwas Ihrer Familienstattenwünschen
standen, sind Sie sehr verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Familien zusammen?
Ja, die Kinder sind schon erwachsen, die sind aus dem Haus.
Aber ich wohne mit meiner Frau natürlich zusammen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe zwei erwachsene Kinder.
Sind Sie gewohnt?
Leider der eine Sohn ist doch auch stark erkrankt.
Da hat man vor sechs Jahren da Bodenkrebs festgestellt.
Welche Krebs haben Sie genannt?
Bodenkrebs.
Das war natürlich ein Schlachanskontor,
aber er gilt jetzt als Geheiert.
Okay, das freut mich.
Das ist aber gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Sie haben schon gesagt.
Ich habe einige Fragen vergessen.
Herr Schröder, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Auslands gewesen?
Ich habe Ihre Frage nicht verstanden, Entschuldigung.
Ich wiederhole, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland
gewesen?
Nein, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Sind Sie gegen Corona oder Kehrzeitbeimpfung?
Da ist mein Hausabgern gründlich.
Gegen Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft, auch wegen der Schule.
Da bin ich auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Das ist gut.
Noch eine Frage.
Reagieren Sie alleigig auf irgendwas?
Z.B. Filanzen, Stau, Polen?
Ich habe natürlich eine Allergie.
Auf Paracetamol.
Das hat man irgendwann mal festgestellt.
Da habe ich mit einem juckenden Ausschlag bekommen.
Das darf ich nicht mehr nehmen.
Ich nehme meinen Außerpalastomol.
Sonst ist nichts.
Zumindest weiß ich von nichts.
Herr Schröder, vielen Dank für Ihre Informationen.
Sie haben alles erzählt.
Vielleicht haben Sie alle eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben alles erzählt.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Geduld.
Was machen Sie gegen meine Schmerzen?
Was können Sie dagegen tun?
Ich möchte ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen raufführen.
Es ist so früher etwas bestimmt etwas zu sagen.
Was für eine Maschine?
Ich möchte etwas sagen.
Was für Untersuchungen machen Sie?
Als erstes würde ich körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich eine Art Brut abnehmen.
Und eine Ultraschallbrüche führen.
Sie haben Hüste.
Das ist eine Art Brut.
Ich habe eine Art Brut.
Ich rauskn mastered scierisch.
Sonst werde ich eine Art Brut.
Darum habe ich eine Art Brut.
Ist es da nötig?
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Sie haben etwasuent Büsch Hola.
Deswegen möchte ich Ihre Lungen auch...
Ja, das kann man ja. Die Strahlendosen sind ja heute noch gut.
Das ist etwas Schlimmeres, aber das ist nötig.
Und es kann man gegebenenfalls, ja,
City, also kompetuere Automografie,
Abdomen, Großführung oder Großbereich.
Aber das ist erst, wenn bei dem anderen nichts rauskommt, oder?
Ja, das könnte sein, aber das nicht muss, ja.
Okay, ja, dann warten wir es ab. Alles klar.
Gut.
Das war alles, aber Sie haben so viel Information gegeben.
Deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie kann ich das alles so einfach...
Also, ich darf mal...
Bei mir ist es nur eine Seite.
Ja, aber Ihre Kopf gibt es noch mehr, oder was?
Ich habe auch so eine Seite, aber so kleine geschrieben,
und kann nicht mehr ich lesen, vielleicht das...
Ich hatte tatsächlich auch etwas aufgeschrieben, wo ich vorher nochmal gucken musste.
Das habe ich auch gemerkt.
Und es war natürlich das Horrorwort, Hemorrhiden.
Das ist ja die böse Tücke für jede Sekretärin.
Ich hasse es, ja.
Gut, also es schreibt sich wirklich blöd,
und ich konnte meine eigene Sprüche mitlesen.
Und dann ist es mir aber wieder eingefallen, was es heißen möchte.
Okay, dann gönnen wir Ihnen ein bisschen Zeit.
Vielleicht hat aber noch jemand Fragen.
Ich habe viele Fragen, aber erstmal Kollegen.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, Dr. Bündnis, wenn Sie keine Fragen haben.
Okay, hat noch jemand anderes Fragen?
Ja, können Sie...
Ich habe natürlich nicht gut.
Vielleicht ist es vielleicht ein bisschen...
Vielleicht ist es vielleicht ein Verstoffung.
Ja, wenn das verstopft, dann ist es ja natürlich knallhart.
Und man kann immer so ein bisschen die Speisereste erkennen,
wenn ich mich gut gekaut habe, ja.
Und wenn ich Durchfall habe, dann ist es halt wässrig mit so Klocken drin.
Ja, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie in letzter Zeit hauptveränderungen oder...
Ah, meine Frau sagt, ich wäre ein bisschen blass und glas.
Blass.
Wie viel kissen Sie, wie viel kissen Sie, wie viel schlafen Sie?
Eins.
Wie viel Treppen steigen Sie, auch wenn Sie stehen bleiben?
Oder Luftnotabeln?
Ja, also zurzeit muss ich tatsächlich auf jedem Treppenabstatt stehen bleiben.
Ja, früher bin ich ja nicht mehr so glas.
Sie haben schon gesagt, meine Beleusung, Sie haben schon.
Ja, hustlen Sie.
Richtig hustlen eigentlich nicht, nein.
Ich habe nur das Gefühl, dass ich so schlafen muss, ja.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpen oder Herzglocken?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Wir haben uns becherlich begonnen.
Noch mal bitte.
Wir haben uns langsam becherlich begonnen.
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen, weil vielleicht haben die schon vorher mal angefangen,
aber irgendwann kommt dann so ein Punkt, wo man merkt, da ist was.
Jetzt tut es weh und das hört nicht wieder auf.
Vielleicht eher plötzlich als langsam.
Sie haben gesagt, aufstossen.
Ja, das ist schon länger, dass ich so ein bisschen saures Ausstöten habe, ne?
Wie viele Jahre?
5 Jahre.
Sind Sie einmal Gasflöse, Fagiö, Dinos, Köke, Dyschführen?
Und dass Sie so einen Schlauch da, ja, das haben die mal gemacht, ja.
Das ist damals gewesen, ja.
Daher habe ich dann das um ein paar Tolen bekommen.
Ja, okay.
Das sieht es ein bisschen...
Ja, irgendwie so, weißt du, wegen Stress oder so, ne?
Dass ich ein bisschen viel Säure hatte.
Das war es.
Gut.
Dr. Alici.
Und vorab, keine Vorab-Fragen müssen,
sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ach so, ja, ist aber nicht.
Sie haben einmal, ja.
Impfung und Wandligation gegen Hemorrhoids.
Ach so, sonst ist das die Hemorrhoidial-Operation, stimmt.
Ja, die habe ich ja angegeben, aber sonst habe ich keine Opfer.
Und Impfungsstatus?
Sie haben geimpft als Corona.
Hat er gefragt.
Wie Kindheit.
Okay.
Können Sie schon, mögen Sie schon?
Opferality?
Weiß ich nicht.
Wo bin ich mir?
Kann ich meine Schrift nicht.
Haben Kollegen, Andreas, Markus?
Können Sie gerne noch ein paar Minuten anfangen?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Mehr als Schiefkind, kannst du nicht.
Also.
Frau Oberrösten, Herr Ärzten,
hätten Sie großartig Zeit für mich.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ja, natürlich.
Klar, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, danke schön.
Also, Tim Schröder ist ein 58-Jährige Patient,
der sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund seit fünf,
sechs Wochen bestehende Mittelbauchschmerzen,
pereumplikanten Abdomenschmerzen,
vorgestellt hat.
Der Patient berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen krampfartig,
wellenformig und sehr heftig sein.
So setzlich teilt er mit,
dass die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkala
beim sechs Einzuordnungen sein.
Und beim Bewegung oder etwas tragen,
schlimmer geworden.
Und die Schmerzen
seien
masslos,
das habe ich noch vergessen.
Hat er noch begleitet, um zu sein Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, ich hoffe das, aber ich habe hier nicht gefunden.
Bestohlen und durch, weil das ist die Ernährung.
Also
dann sind den passierten Folgen der Begleitzentrumen auch gefallen.
Er klagt über
täglich viermal
und nach Schweiß.
Manchmal für Sturpfung
und
Abgetitlosigkeit,
Abgeschlagenheit.
Er hat in der
letzter Zeit,
seit acht Monaten,
drei Kilo abgegeben.
Abgenommen.
Er hat auch
Einsuchlarvenprobleme.
Einsachprobleme?
Okay.
Die
haben wir hier.
Anvor er krank und
leide er an,
bis PFC,
dagegen nehme er täglich
um eine Person einmal ein.
Manchmal zweimal.
Und wegen Kniebeschwader
seit zwei Monaten
nehme er bei Bedarf überprüfen.
Und
er leide an
seit zwei Monaten
und hat in eine Wandligation durchgeführt.
Und
er leide an auch
ein Bluthochdruck.
Im Kaltonie.
Er war satan täglich einmal.
Er ist raucher
in 30 Packungen.
Und nehme täglich ein, zwei Gelass Wein.
Und nimmt kein Drogen.
Er sei gegend.
Und er lege auch
in Parastomol.
Und
er ist
verheiratet.
Seine Kinder schon
erwachsen.
Und wir haben nur seine Frau.
Seine Frau.
Seine
Frau.
Sohn.
Seine
Sohn hatte
aber
aber so seit
er ist
sei gesund.
Weil er
ist ein Lehrer.
Und
also
als Familienamnese
steht nur sein Vater
und er ist
ein Lehrer.
Und er ist
Was ist denn jetzt die Anlosung?
Ja.
Also
das ist der
Vorbild.
Als Differenzialdiagnose
kommen
in Betrag
die
Restauranteritis,
Magenkrebs,
Restaurantestinalkrebs,
Kolonkrebs,
Pancreatitis,
wenn ich
kann sein,
Kolosistitis,
Gastritis.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch?
Ja, als
erst Massnahme würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Und worauf achten Sie dabei besonders?
Ja, also
so als möchte ich den
Patienten oskalitieren
danach eine Palpation durchbühren.
Und da möchte ich eine
akut
Abdomen ausschließen.
Ich möchte untersuchen,
gibt eine
Loslassschmerzen
oder eine Muskelspannung,
ja, so
erhörten, erhärtationen, befunden,
versteht oder nicht, ja.
Und
natürlich, ich möchte auch
Apparitionen, Diagnosen durchführen,
Blutabnehmen
und da Blutbild,
vielleicht Lebewahrter,
Nierenwörter
und... Was erwarten Sie denn im Blutbild?
Ja, so, sonst ja
eine
Schmerzen erwarte ich einen
Blass- und Schlapp.
Also
vielleicht
eine so etwas chronische
Krankheit, ja, deswegen...
Was erwarten Sie im Blutbild?
Blutbild, ja, also Blutbild
hatte ich etwas animier, könnte ich sagen, ja.
Genau.
Vielleicht könnte auch die Lyokostosum sein, ja.
Stimmt, ja, ja.
Und das war jetzt so das nächste Liegendste, ne,
weil der Blass ist so müde und schlapp,
dass der wahrscheinlich eine Anime hat.
Aber gleichzeitig, vielleicht
die BSG, auch Blutsenkung,
Geschwindigkeit auch, erhörter sein, ja.
Ob der Entzündung, der da hat, klappt.
Und was machen Sie denn noch
an
die Diagnostik?
Also ich möchte
eine Stuhlpest
durchführen, ja.
Ja, auf, ein Stuhlpest, auf.
Also unterricht, also
als körperliche Untersuchung habe ich
vergessen, ich möchte auch gerne eine
digitale Untersuchung durchführen.
So versuche ich eine
Melanöne geht, oder nicht.
Blutung geht, oder nicht.
Wie ist die Hemorrhoide?
Das war nicht Hemorrhoide, vorher könnte auch eine
Krebs sein, ja, das redet da.
Also
Apparativ-Masken haben
würde ich so erst vielleicht
in den Bauchbereich durchführen.
Ja.
Also
wie ich gesagt,
können wir auch eine
Röckchen mit Abdomen
und Torax
durchführen. Ja, im Abdomen,
was würden Sie da, würden Sie da
durchführen?
Also vielleicht eine Belöhung können wir
suchen, eine Verstuppung.
Manchmal hat der Patient
Verstuppung,
vielleicht er könnte
eine Magen oder Magen nicht, aber
Colin Karstenau sein,
deswegen können wir eine Verstuppung
machen. Ja.
Und was wäre denn sicherlich der
optimale diagnostische Weg,
wenn wir das Colin Karstenau untersuchen wollen?
Also Colin noch Skobi, ja.
Natürlich, genau.
Alles klar.
Was würde denn für den Morbus Kronen sprechen?
Also
eine
chronischen Krankheit, ja,
chronischen entsündliche Darankrankheit, ja.
Meistens betroffene
Teil von den
Lünder Terminalillons,
die Ende der Illons.
Wie gesagt, chronische
Was ist da so lange Zeit gibt
für die
spezifischen
Zentrumen, das heißt,
Wellenformen
Bauchschmerzen, aber das ist mit einer Schuhe, ja,
nicht wie eine Wellenformen.
Also, ja, genau, da sind es ja so
Schuhe, ja.
Also die, sie sind auch ...
Aber das war ja
der Hauptverdachtstiagnose.
Ja, das war meine Verdachtstiagnose,
das ist nicht fast, aber
ich gufe es seit.
Ich gehe mal an die Manöverkritik, ja.
Also
in der Fallbeschreibung
ist es tatsächlich eine ihrer Differenzialliagnosen,
nämlich es ist das Colin Karstenau, ja.
Und der Kron ist hier als Differenzialdiagnose auch geblieben, aber ja.
Was ihnen vielleicht ein bisschen eine Falle gestellt hat, das ist ihr Problem mit Zeitangeben.
Da stimmen nämlich so einige nicht.
Und zwar, ich habe das schon relativ häufig darüber gesprochen, dass das manchmal so
zwischfältig ist.
Aufgefallen ist mir das einmal, bei dem Sohn mit dem Hodenkarzen.
Der hatte nicht mit sechs Jahren, sondern vor sechs Jahren.
Das Hodenkarzen umtritt normalerweise bei jungen Männern aus.
Ja und also der hatte das nicht mit sechs Jahren, sondern seit oder vor sechs Jahren ist es
auch getreten und dann ist der behandelt worden.
Das war das eine.
Das hat mich verpasst.
Ja, dann hatte die drei Kilo eben nicht in sechs Monaten verloren, sondern in sechs
Wochen.
Ich habe keine.
Es gibt natürlich ein gravierender Unterschied und würde natürlich verstärkt diese Tumordiagnose
forcieren.
Das habe ich hier in den Sachtwochen geschrieben.
Und die, das kommt noch mal vor.
Das kommt noch mal vor und zwar die Knieschmerzen.
Da haben sie gesagt, seit zwei Monaten.
Die hatte aber seit zwei Jahren.
Und und die Hämorrhiden, die hatte schon seit vier Jahren.
Da waren aber zwei Monate vor zwei Monaten war die letzte Bandligatur.
Ja, also das ist die Zeit spannenden und Zeitangaben.
Da sind sie offensichtlich in Schliggern geraten.
Ja, manchmal hängt es wirklich an einem Wort, ja, ob man sagt, seit dem so und so viel
in Lebensjahr vor so und so viel Jahren mit so und so viel Jahren, das sind alles feine
Unterschiede, wo man genau hinhören muss.
Und also er hat seit vier Jahren Hämorrhiden, die mehrfach operiert wurden, zuletzt vor
zwei Monaten.
Okay.
Und ja, und da sehrlich hat es, glaube ich, bei ihnen jetzt dazu geführt, wegen dieser Gewichtsverlust.
3 Kilo in sechs Monaten ist ja nicht so wahnsinnig doll.
Ja, aber in sechs Wochen 3 Kilo ist er schon ziemlich heftig.
Genau.
Und ja, und was sie, was sie der Oberärztin auch nicht erzählt haben, wann werden seine
Schmerzen schlechter?
Nicht bei Bewegung.
Da haben sie etwas Witziges gesagt.
Ich nehme an, Sie haben ein deutsches Wort nicht verstanden.
Ich habe gesagt, bei Stuhlgang.
Stuhlgang heißt Verdauung.
Wenn der aufs Klo geht, hat der Schmerzen.
Und Sie haben gesagt, bei Bewegung oder wenn er aus schweres trägt?
Erinnern Sie sich?
Ja, das habe ich ganz.
Das haben Sie gesagt.
Also, der Stuhlgang hat nichts mit Stühlen zu tun und nichts mit Bewegung,
sondern das ist eben auf die Klose zu gehen.
Ja.
Und da hat er halt mehr Schmerzen.
Und ich denke mal, auch das wieder eine sprachliche Falle.
Woher kommt das Wort?
Früher hatte man eine Nachtstuhl.
Ja.
Und wenn man die Nachtstuhl benutzt hat, dann hatte man einen Stuhlgang.
Man ist zum Nachtstuhl gegangen und hat da sein Geschäft gemacht.
Ja.
Und deswegen heißt das, wenn man nicht irgendein obstönes Wort sagen will,
heißt das halt, hatten Sie Verdauung oder hatten Sie Stuhlgang?
Ja.
Und ja, ich denke mal, dass das wahrscheinlich daher kam, diese Vorverständnisse.
Welche Wörter können wir schreiben?
Wir können Verdauung sagen und Stuhlgang.
Können Sie auch sagen, das ist eigentlich normal.
Also, das war früher doch so, ich sehe das noch vor mir.
Die Schwestern, die früher mit einem Fiebertermometer kamen und mit so einer Eierohr zum Puls messen.
Ja.
Und die Fraschen hatten dann ihre Fieberkurve dabei.
Heute ist es ja alles digital.
Also, die hatten ihre Fieberkurve dabei.
Und dann schrieben sie ein, das passt ich, 36, 9 und Puls 83 und dann eben Stuhlgang, ja, oder eben nein.
Ja.
Und also, das sind die beiden Begriffe, die man so umgangssprachlich verwendet.
Und wenn jemand jetzt überhaupt nicht darauf reagiert, also jemand, der vielleicht sehr schlicht vom Bildungsgrad ist oder so, oder auch, ja, dann kann man, können sie auf die Toilette gehen oder so, ne?
Das, ja.
Also, ne?
Aber eigentlich verdauen können die meisten Verdauungs-Stuhlgang.
Na?
Okay.
Gut.
Mir ist auch gefallen, aber sie haben es ja quasi angekündigt, ne?
Dass sie viel aufgeschrieben haben, bisschen Probleme hatten, das zusammenzufassen.
Die Befragung war ja super.
Sie haben ja, sie haben ja sehr konsequent gefragt.
Sie waren sehr nett, sie waren sehr variantreich.
Sie haben nicht immer das Gleiche gefragt, sondern immer schön verschieden die Fragen formuliert.
Und, was eben auch super war, wenn ich ihnen so ein bisschen zu viel Informationen gegeben habe, haben sie die hinterher sortiert.
Ja, genau.
Das war klasse, ne?
Und ganz so flüssig und ganz so locker war es dann hinterher im Arztgespräch, nicht?
Und eben diese Zeitgeschichten, das ist so ein bisschen auffällig.
Ist vielleicht so etwas, was man sich nochmal klarmachen muss, wie das von der deutschen Sprache ist, ne?
Mit 18 Jahren, seit 18 Jahren, vor 18 Jahren, ne?
Vor 18 Jahren heißt es, ein eigenes ist abgeschlossen.
Mhm.
Und seit 18 Jahren, dann hat es vor 18 Jahren angefangen, dauert bis heute.
Und so diese Geschichten halten, ne?
So ein bisschen darauf achten.
Ja.
Gut.
Ich hoffe, Herr Schröder geht es bald wieder besser.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wird er operiert werden.
Und natürlich, klar, wenn er einen Colon-Katzinom hat, geht man auch noch auf Metastasenbrühe, ne?
Mhm.
Das ist logisch.
Klar.
Gut.
Ja.